so I'll be talking about spire it's a
web application framework for Python if
anybody here has lived in the our world
you may have heard of shiny or you shiny
a very similar package for our it's
basically just a very easy way to turn
data and plots into interactive web
applications spire depends on cherry pie
to provide a server in the back end
jinjja 24 templating so you don't have
to write any HTML or JavaScript
matplotlib for the basic plots and
pandas because we're working with data
here assuming you don't have any
problems with those dependencies to
install aspire you just do pip install
data spire and this is going to be a
very example driven talk so if you want
to follow along I encourage you to do so
we'll start just by talking about kind
of the mechanics of how to create an app
and how to launch it so from spire you
import the server module and that server
module has a nap class so every app that
you create it's going to be a class and
it needs to inherit the server app class
so to create an app this is all you do I
don't recommend launching this in
ipython notebook the recommended way to
launch an app is just from the command
line so here's that empty app app that I
just showed you and to launch it we just
do Python the name of the file and I
know this is probably hard to see but
this will give you some feedback and
tell you where it's being served so this
is being served locally and if we copy
that into our browser we get an app
which is empty right now because we
haven't put anything in it but we'll
walk through a couple of examples to
show how to build these one piece at a
time so the first thing we need to do is
add inputs to our app inputs outputs and
controls are all just lists of
dictionaries each one of those elements
as a dictionary specifying the
properties of that element so in this
case we want to add a single input it's
going to be a text box so input type its
text and then it's got some properties
like a variable name label and initial
value so if i run this
and refresh this page I've added an
input but just a text box if we want to
change the input type we can just change
that property save it and reload the
page and now it's a slider
so next we'll add an output we're just
going to add a plot like the inputs
outputs is just a list of dictionaries
each one of those dictionaries
specifying the properties of the outputs
in this case the output type is a plot
we've got an output ID and we want this
to load when the page loads so we'll
have on page load is equal true save
that now when we refresh we have an
output which has no content because we
haven't told the app what should be in
the output so we'll do that next so to
create the content for any of the
outputs you need to override a method
that comes with the the server app in
this case we need to override the get
plot method and so the get ply method is
going to take some inputs which are
supplied by the inputs and your panel
over here and it should output a pipe
lot figure
so you see the get plot method takes
params as its only input and parameters
the dictionary which is going to hold
all the input values it's a keyed on the
variable name so in our inputs we have a
variable named as one of the property
keys and values in this case the
variable name is frequent or the Freak
is we're going to have a sine wave that
we're going to plot so we define f as
the Freak value of the params dictionary
most of these inputs come back as
strings so if we want them to be
anything else like an integer or float
we need to cast as as such hey we're
just defining the x-axis and then
creating a pipeline figure
so now with the get ply method
overridden we save and reload our page
and now we have the plot and if we
change our input value the plot updates
so notice that the inputs and outputs
not only specify what types of elements
to include on the page but also how
they're connected to each other so part
of the the properties of the inputs is
an action ID and that tells the app when
this input state changes I want to
update whatever this action ID is
pointing at and kick this case the
action ID is pointing to our plot output
so the output ID for the plot is plot
sine wave and that action ID references
that output ID so a very simple app very
simple relationship and update to the
input state tells the output to update
briefly just kind of one piece of what's
going on under the hood here spire uses
jinja to templating to generate the HTML
and javascript so basically there's a
bunch of templating pieces that look
kind of like this when you pass in the
inputs and the output dictionaries
jinjja renders those into the HTML and
javascript that creates the page you're
looking at this is boring or
uninteresting or foreign to you that's
okay you don't need to know anything
about HTML Javascript all you need to
know is Python to create a web
application with spire okay so let's
build on this and look at a slightly
more interesting example so let's
suppose you've written a function to go
to the web get some historical stock
data
and turn that into a data frame so
that's what this get data function does
it takes a ticker value so the symbol
that represents whatever company you're
interested in it goes to the web and
turns that into a pandas dataframe so
this function here returns a data frame
once you have a data frame pandas has a
nice method called plot that's really
really simple to use and creates nice
looking plots of the data and the data
frame so here's the data we're getting
back from this API that we're hitting
and just calling plot on that data frame
returns this plot for us so once you've
done that work to get the data and
create a plot we're going to now turn
that into a web application that's
interactive okay so as before we define
a single input and a single output the
output again is a plot but in this case
we're going to use a drop-down menu so
we just do input type drop-down and then
rather than having a single value a
drop-down menu has an option of values
each one of those has a label which is
what you see in the UI and a value which
is the value passed to the get plot
method in this case when that option is
selected this get data method here is
just exactly what we saw before it goes
to the API grabs the data turns it into
a Python data for pandas dataframe and
then get plot is just the app method
that we need to override to actually
generate the plot so in this case get
plot is calling getdata method and then
just returning a pipe lot figure
ok
so we update our app script save it and
now when we reload thank you
all right now when we relaunch that app
reload the page now we have that plot
that we were seeing before and a drop
down menu input so as we change the the
company that we want to grab data for
the plot calls the getdata method to go
to the API grabs the data and turns it
into a map plot lib plot so
architectural II this is similar it's
the same as the the first app that we
built it's a single input a single
outfit they communicate directly through
the action ID of the input and the
output idea of the output if you wanted
to add a second output that's definitely
possible who comes a little bit more
complicated in terms of how things talk
to each other so again we're going to
add we're going to add a table this time
as the output so the input is the same
as we had before it's at this time we
don't have an action ID so the change to
the input will not will not create a
change in the output instead we're going
to have control and controls or anything
that have an action that cannot update
output so in this case our control is
going to be a button the action on this
button is to click it so clicking the
button is what's going to trigger an
output an update to the outputs so we
have the plot output again and now we've
added an output type of table so these
look kind of what you would expect them
to look like the only thing that we've
added is a control ID this control ID is
a reference to the control that's going
to trigger an update in the output so
the control ID here is update data which
is the control ID for that button that
we created
alright so if we save that refresh our
page we get two outputs the plot that we
saw before and now this pandas dataframe
has been turned into a sortable HTML
table so if we click on any of these
columns sortable if we change the input
nothing happens until we click the
button and the clicking the button
updates both of the outputs I should
mention that just like with the plot we
had to override the get plot method to
actually generate the content for that
plot for a table the the actual content
comes from a getdata method which we can
conveniently already created to get the
data so this getdata method is actually
the thing that's generating the content
for the table and that's expected to
return a pandas dataframe which is why
you need pandas first fire okay finally
we will add two more things so it can
get a little bit crowded if you have a
lot of outputs on what in one panel so
you can add tabs to your app just like
with with inputs and outputs tabs is a
list of things in this case it's just a
list of tap titles and then each output
now is going to live in a tab so it
needs to reference the tablet it lives
in so within each of these output
dictionaries we now have a reference to
the tab so the plot output is going to
live in the plot tab and the table
output is going to live in the table tab
we're also going to do a little trick
such that a change in the input now
updates both outputs so each input only
has a single action ID so you can only
directly update a single output with the
change to the state of the input however
the action ID can reference either an
output ID or a control ID so if we
reference the control rather than the
output directly then a change to the
state of the input is essentially taking
an action on that control in the case of
a button it would be like clicking the
button whenever you change the state of
the input by doing so you basically make
the existence of the button superfluous
so to not confuse anybody who can
actually have a hidden control type
which basically just routes the action
of the input to the outputs that we want
so if we save that a refresh our page
now we have both of our outputs but in
different tabs let me no longer have a
button a change to the input routes our
action through control to both of the
outputs
so kind of what that looks like diagram
we have our input which has an action ID
which references the control and that
control an action on that control is
what actually updates the output so
we're indirectly updating the outputs
through a change in state of the input
so these are just two very simple
examples there are certainly cases much
more complicated cases and I think the
best way to really dig into this is to
look at the examples there are ton of
them on github within the examples
directory there's a live running example
of this at Adam hajari com this is
basically just the the stocks example
that we ran through it's got the plots
and the tables another output type is
HTML there are also two methods that you
can override called get custom j/s and
get custom CSS so if you wanted to do
something fancy like supply your own
JavaScript through a package like okay
you could do that and so there's a
bouquet plot that we're generating by
supplying some HTML Javascript CSS you
don't have to write any of that ok
actually writes it all for you you just
need to tell the spire up where to get
it there's an example of that in the
github repo but this works just like
you'd expect except you have all the
nice functionality
ok
great and I guess I didn't say this yet
but I'm Adam pajara a data scientist at
next big sound and you can contact me or
follow me on Twitter so that's all I've
got any questions yeah render the one I
think I used something called sortable
sort table yeah pandas actually has a
method called to HTML which will turn
your data frame into the table so but to
make a sortable you need to use the
getdata method
I definitely haven't hit the upper limit
yet i've loaded a dataframe five
thousand rows before and that seems to
be fine it's slow but it's past five
thousand i'm not sure what it would be
yeah
where it's styled to be something
different than I don't have have an
example I spent all my time just styling
the generic version of it but you can
definitely pass in your own CSS and
change the color of the buttons or the
style of anything if you want to
override any of that debt style
it doesn't replace it it just add to it
okay
sorry I don't understand
I see like you want to put a plot figure
inside of HTML yeah you can definitely
do that so these are just to generate
all of this stuff
it's hard to do with one hand
so they're just a call to the table
input and point for instance to generate
the table so if you were to put this
input or this endpoint into HTML it
would just put this table into whatever
HTML you want to surround it in that
make sense yeah
yeah yeah and that was actually I
started out in the data science we're
losing our and that was one of the the
fact that our had shiny was one of the
things that kind of kept me in the our
environment which is so easy to turn
your whatever project you're working on
into a client-facing web app and I
should mention that my default this
serves up the web app locally on port
8080 you can override those into the
launch method so if you wanted to host
this to external traffic you would just
do host equals 0 2 0 0 0 and then put it
on whatever port you want it so if you
wanted on to port 80 you could do that
and then you could put it on an ec2
instance or wherever you want to give it
to a client or anybody externally yeah
I mean it's by design it's simple it's
supposed to be very simple to to get it
off the ground and in no time at all so
it's not it's not yeah you could have as
many inputs and outputs as you want so
in that sense it scales well but it's
it's not designed to be the webpage for
your company right it's designed to make
simple web apps to export to somebody
that you want to see the data but don't
necessarily want to see the code that
generated the data that's a great
question so the params dictionary here
has all of the the input values but it
also has an output ID key so if you have
two plots they're both going to call get
plot but within get plot you would have
if output ID equals output one generate
this plot if output ID equals output to
the generate this other plot and I
actually was a little bit sloppy here in
my simple example I called the GC f
method which is get current funk or get
current bigger that doesn't work if
you're generating more than one plot you
actually need to create a figure object
and then has to return that and get plot
so don't do this don't do the GCF method
if you have more than one plot yeah
yeah there's not an easy way to do that
now and I haven't really experimented
with it but an idea that I had is there
are libraries to connect to Google Docs
so for instance you could have somebody
create a Google spreadsheet with their
data and then reference it through the
interface so they would just supply like
the URL for their Google Doc and that
could generate the data for you
yeah and hopefully somewhere down the
road we'll have functionality to
actually upload your own data that
that's kind of something we haven't
built yet great well thank you guys for
listening